hello and welcome to this video playing
today from France but definitely not go
before gather after losing the silly
game in the dragon souls giddyup - that
is a that is rare line um how does that
work out there's some queen III business
I believe that is a yes it's happening
why'd wants to control d5 we should be
form basically saying I don't care about
the dark squares okay I'll just go back
down get to t5
okay well the other one I don't know
what's better this is maybe more forcing
at the end the question is what about
the c7 point okay that you can play but
of course I have I have bishops III
stuff that looks critical
95 that doesn't work in can play c5u
yeah antinea I just I should win some
stuff quiz
now let's just take take material here
and not think for too long it could join
it gives me the real girl also okay I
now take it I had to fool look now for
porn or something I'm rescuing this okay
we just continues okay okay so how do I
return it only this way check
black forfeits due to this connections
just kind of it's um so that's a look
them didn't do any the opening was a bit
strange there are those IDs em and I
don't know if you reacted well here and
night before okay
I was kind of thinking I just hate again
it might be a move but it is actually
good it is actually good I thought I
could do this but you didn't see this
move and that's really a problem
okay so night before I that that that
was better so I probably have to play
this then instead so let's yeah this is
really an option and later this idea
okay so night h3 was imprecise but he
has to improve somewhere here I am I
mean like this move is stopped working I
think yeah takes takes 98 is given as
best by the engine he already loses upon
this is probably probably done this is
even worse okay yeah I was briefly
thinking that some some move like this
intending c5 could be strong it is also
quite good yeah but there's no need to
not take it and here I mean I'm just I'm
just
in exchange and now we've got some got
disasters opening but I made a bet or a
choice then Bishop g2 was a bit a lot
better than than this one okay guys
thanks for watching